foreign
Ty is in Cedar Rapids hi Randy welcome
to the Ramsay show
hey guys I appreciate y'all taking my
call sure what's up
hey so I've been following y'all's
program for a while now and we've gotten
to the point where I'm in uh maybe it
does four five and six and I'm just not
really feeling traction and so my
question for you guys is uh is there is
there something I'm missing I don't want
to be just reactive to things but
proactive in some of this
um so we have what do you mean you're
not feeling traction
like it's been a couple years and like
life keeps hitting us so like for
example we had uh what's called a rate
show which is basically an online
hurricane of sustained winds of 180
miles an hour so some stuff on an old
house that insurance won't cover that we
had to prepare
um we had two babies in the midst of
this journey as well so uh saved up for
those and paid cash for all those things
uh we now have paid for paid cash for
both of our reliable cars now that we've
upgraded so we've been invest in uh 27
sir wow you're killing it dude this is
called life and you're winning it yeah I
mean I missed the part where you're not
getting traction what are you talking
about babies paid for storm repairs I
mean you you know you're rocking this
is we just we've been investing you know
15 20 now for for a couple years
uh not quite so that's what you should
not be doing by 15 percent
it uh we have two uh five years left on
our yeah you should be doing 15 at baby
step four onto your house no more not
20.
you gotcha so dial that back so you're
gonna have a paid off house when you're
32. you know who would trade places with
you everybody 100 million Americans
yeah let me let me let me let me in all
honesty let me tell you what I think it
is you thought
it would feel differently
and everyone I've ever sat down with
whether they are multi-multi
multi-millionaire or they're a pro
athlete or they thought that
there would be this resolution
that suddenly dad would text out of the
blue and be like hey I have never called
you and told you I'm really proud of you
I want you not proud of you that call is
never coming right or that I was just
going to wake up and suddenly like I'm a
good looking guy I feel great that that
that that that resolution never comes
and so then you're in a like you're in a
position brother where you're gonna
start doing dumb stuff if you continue
to chase feelings instead of just stay
in the path stay in the path stay in the
path
because you're going to start seeking
feeling does that make sense
yes sir and people rarely cheat on their
spouse because of their spouse they
cheat on their spouse because it makes
them feel alive again
they rarely go buy a new sports car
because it's a great purchase but it
makes them feel alive for five seconds
and you're in danger of going down that
road if you if you deviate from the past
where the path is so important man
because it gives us something to lean on
when we quote unquote don't feel right
that's why I map out my workout programs
because I don't I don't feel like it in
the morning right but I've already got
it written out man stay on the path stay
on the path from two old guys way older
than you bro you are doing great so good
man stay on the path how often have you
heard that over the years oh it happens
all the time yeah when you get to baby
step four it just slows down that's it
changes it's the adrenaline changes from
intensity to life this is great to
intentional
and intentional is not nearly as
exciting as intensity yeah and so
intentional is a was a marathon
intensity is a Sprint it changes
everything